>>Female Presenter: So, I'm Julie Wiskirchen
from the Authors at Google team here at Google
Los Angeles.
And today, I'm very excited to welcome Greg
Koch, who is the co-founder and CEO of Stone
Brewing Company.
Please welcome Greg.
[applause]
Just a little bit of background on Greg.
He and his partner, Steve Wagner, founded
Stone in 1996 and it has become one of the
fastest growing and highest rated breweries
in the world, brewing 148 thousand, 686 barrels
in 2011.
Stone is the 14th largest craft brewery in
the United States and the largest American-owned
brewery in the Southwestern United States--a
position it achieved without advertising,
discounting, or giving away freebies.
Greg passionately believes that environmental
and social sustainability go hand-in-hand
with brewing mind-blowing beer.
And today, here's here to talk about his book,
"The Craft of Stone Brewing Co.: Liquid Lore,
Epic Recipes, and Unabashed Arrogance."
So, please join me in welcoming Greg.
>>Greg Koch: Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you very much.
It's nice to be here, right at the heart of
Google.
[laughter]
Venice Beach.
I gave a little delay there, so you can edit
that however you see fit.
[laughter]
So, yeah.
I started Stone a few years ago with my partner,
Steve Wagner.
And let's get right into it.
I have a premise for you.
And this premise is gonna lay out how the
United States became the greatest brewing
nation in the world.
Fact.
It is, today, the greatest brewing nation
in the world.
You can acknowledge that if you like.
[clapping]
[laughter]
You can acknowledge that if you like.
No bullshit.
I've always wanted to say that in a Google
talk.
Actually, San Diego alone, at the most recent
World Beer Cup, won more medals than Belgium,
Germany, and UK combined.
And in addition to that, the majority of judges
at the World Beer Cup were from Europe.
[pause]
The Financial Times in the UK said, "There
is a second American craft, revolution going
on.
It's a craft beer revolution and it's breaking
out all over the country."
But before this bright sunshine that we have
now, there were the dark days.
But let's go back a little bit.
[laughter]
In fact, let's go back a lot.
Hop in with me.
We'll fire up the flux capacitor, go back
in time to when their transportation method
was a horse-drawn cart.
And each brewery in the United States only
had a distribution area that was the distance
that a horse-drawn cart could go out from
the brewery and back within one day.
But over time, with consolidation and changes
in the Industrial Revolution, with transportation
and refrigeration--
[pause]
the beer landscape in the United States changed
dramatically.
We went from 32 hundred plus breweries in
the United States to, well, let's find out.
The era of commodity beer got really in full
swing in the very end of the late-1800s and
the early-1900s, where--.
Well, I can't imagine going into a saloon
like this and asking for anything other than
beer.
If you'd said, "Which beers do you have?"
You would have probably gotten a pretty funny
look, let alone calling it out stylistically
or brand name wise.
It just wasn't the way it was done.
It wasn't what was offered.
It's not like this beautiful cornucopia that
we have here today.
And then, along comes Carrie Nation.
I like to call her the "Mother of Organized
Crime."
[laughter]
Carrie Nation, of course, was the leader of
the women's temperance movement, which led
forth Prohibition and the rise of the true
godfather of crime and some very, very stylishly
dressed people.
[laughter]
[pause]
Bless you, Gene Roddenberry.
[laughter]
[laughs]
I love that episode.
And certainly, led to a lot of crying in the
streets, even though there was virtually not
much choice in the landscape of beer.
There was still the choice of having beer,
except for this period of time.
And there, of course, was a lot of that.
People weren't happy.
I wouldn't be happy.
And almost 13 years later, Prohibition was
repealed in 1933.
[pause]
Well, it's interesting to take a look at the
US brewery count.
And you can see, again, in the late-1800s,
nearly, or in excess of 32 hundred breweries.
And take a look at that line.
It dips down all the way, of course, during
the Prohibition years to zero, but you can
draw your own line across to what it would've
been like, likely, if Prohibition had never
existed.
Consolidation, mass commodification, homogenization
was happening pretty much every category in
food and beverage and a lot of other things
in the United States during this era as the
Industrial Revolution kept chugging and chugging
and chugging along, leading us to years later,
when in 1979, we had the low point of just
42 breweries in the country.
All of them being essentially the same.
Well, all but thankfully, one-- Anchor Steam.
The Anchor brewery up in San Francisco was
really the only brewery that was brewing anything
that was functionally different from pretty
much everything else across the nation for
its flagship beer.
The other 41 breweries, their flagship beers
were essentially competing with each other
in the same space.
Well, Jimmy Carter, in his infinite wisdom,
actually removed the excise tax for home-brewing.
So, he did it while home-brewing was legal
in many states up to that point.
He actually had to fill out a lot of forms
and pay excise tax.
And Jimmy Carter wisely got rid of that, freeing
it up to really start this landscape of home-brewing
and this culture of home-brewing, led by Charlie
Papazian.
Who recognizes this man right here?
A couple of hands.
This guy is considered to be the father of
modern home-brewing.
[pause]
Speaking of which, let's cheers to Charlie
and all of you guys here.
>>Audience: Cheers.
[clapping]
>>Greg Koch: Cheers.
Or, this is Oaked Arrogant Bastard Ale.
I will teach you the Arrogant Bastard Ale
cheer.
It goes very simply: Here's to me.
[laughter]
And so dawned a new era as home-brewers helped
stretch the bounds of what was considered
to be beer.
In 1978, Charlie Papazian started the Association
of Brewers.
And then in 1981, Charlie started the Great
American Beer Festival.
And then in 1982, he wrote "The Joy of Homebrewing."
And what was I doing in this era?
Yeah.
In 1984, I graduated from high school.
[laughter]
But in 2010, Charlie was honored with the
Belgian Knighthood of the brewers of the Belgian
Brewers Federation.
And I was honored to stand next to Charlie
to also receive that same honor.
So, in the late-'80s and early-'90s, it was
boom times for craft brewing.
Things really started to take off.
And in fact, the US brewery count went up
dramatically.
You can see that in the '80s and early-'90s,
it started really, really going north.
And beer was flourishing across the nation.
And people were learning about the different
styles of beer that were available--not just
the fizzy yellow stuff.
[sighs] But then, the first bust.
The bubble burst.
In 1996, all of a sudden, the growth curve
went from sharp to essentially flat within
just a year and a half time period.
You can see the volume growth went to almost
nothing.
Now, if you were gonna open up a brewery--
[laughter]
when would you pick, in this curve, to open
up?
Well, yeah.
Somewhere in there, that's when we started.
And let's see.
Oh, I don't know.
Maybe I should pick the bottom.
[laughter]
Or maybe just ever so slightly before it hits
bottom.
Yeah, that seems like a good time.
Well, we didn't know, but that's when Steve
and I decided to open up the Stone Brewing
Company.
We didn't realize that this was happening
when we opened up.
We only knew that wholesalers, retailers,
well, pretty much everybody or nobody wanted
our beer.
We couldn't sell our beer to anybody--hardly.
All the wholesalers would tell us, "You know
what?
It's imports is where it's at."
And all the retailers would say, "Hey, we're
DC-ing, we're discontinuing all these brands.'
Well, that is when we opened and this is what
it looked like.
I'd like to actually bring up my co-author
in the Stone book, Randy Clemens.
And we're gonna bring him into the conversation
and continue.
[pause]
>>Randy Clemens: Here we get intimate.
>>Greg Koch: Whoa.
That wasn't part of the arrangement, Randy.
[pause]
>>Randy Clemens: Thank you.
>>Greg Koch: Sure.
Where's mine?
>>Randy Clemens: Hi.
How you guys doing?
>>Male #1: Good.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
>>Greg Koch: Randy Clemens, everybody.
Co-author.
Stone Brewing.
Right here.
[applause]
We'll sell you one.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
So, we're doing this a different way than
we've done it before.
I'm not typically involved in these kinds
of things, but if followed suit in that we
just more or less did this in writing a book.
I knew a bit about beer and a little bit about
Stone, but I got to know more just working
with Greg.
So, we're gonna try it this way.
Enough of that slide, though.
>>Greg Koch: Cheers.
>>Randy Clemens: Thank you.
[clink]
So, if you could just talk a little bit about
the pre-history--how you and Steve met.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
So, I actually--.
I give a lot to Anchor Steam because Anchor
Steam was the first beer that opened my eyes.
I was living in Los Angeles.
And I went to this dive bar in downtown LA
in the Warehouse District through the Artist
Loft District, and it was called Al's Bar.
And they had, here and knowing--.
>>Male #2: Alameda?
>>Greg Koch: What's that?
>>Male #2: Alameda.
>>Greg Koch: Sort of off Alameda, yeah.
Traction.
And it was an incredible hole in the wall.
It had just a porthole, no sign, and it was
off this very, very small street in a very
gritty part of town.
But they had about six beer on tap.
And I would get Anchor.
I saw Anchor Steam.
I decided to try it.
And it was then that I realized that it was
the only beer as it warmed up, it just didn't
taste like hell.
[laughter]
'Cause the rest of the beers they had on tap
were fizzy, yellow beer.
And I had this reaction, like "Wow, beer can
taste like this."
I had no idea because previous to that, I
had only been aware of the existence of the
fizzy, yellow commodity side of the equation.
So, that was that first spark in my journey
towards craft beer.
Over the years, I started visiting small breweries,
going to beer festivals, and especially beer
events and so on.
During a similar time period, Steve Wagner,
my business partner at Stone, had been taught
to home-brew by one of his band mates.
He was in a band here in LA.
And he and I then ran into each other at a
little class at UC Davis called "A Sensory
Evaluation of Beer."
Beer geek class.
And I saw Steve during this class.
And we came up to each other in the break
realizing that we'd actually met a few years
earlier through a common friend in the music
industry.
That sparked our conversation on the beer
side of the equation.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
So, you meet at this class at Davis.
[pause]
Was the conversation had, then and there,
about potentially starting a brewery?
Was a spark lit?
And where did it go from there?
I mean, how did Davis get you both to San
Diego?
>>Greg Koch: The conversation actually didn't
begin there.
Although, not quite literal of "Hey, do you
wanna maybe start a brewery together?"
But instead, we had that in the back of our
mind as we started the conversation of, "Hey,
maybe we should get together and do a home-brew"
Steve was actually living in a little bungalow
in Santa Monica, just a hop, skip, and a jump
from here.
And I started going over to his house and
playing assistant home-brew lackey because
he had been actually, he was quite experienced
at home-brewing at that point.
>>Randy Clemens: So you were sanitizing everything.
>>Greg Koch: I was sanitizing.
I was the bottle washer, cleaner, sanitizer.
Do it again 'cause he would then watch me
do it all and instruct me I didn't do it right
so I could do it again.
I think he was teaching me to wax on and wax
off.
[laughter]
>>Randy Clemens: Gotcha.
So--.
>>Greg Koch: Did I answer the question?
I forgot what the question was already.
>>Randy Clemens: You started.
You started.
So, home-brewing See, this is why I'm here.
[laughter]
So, Steve does some professional brewing in-between.
And how does San Diego come into the equation?
>>Greg Koch: OK.
So, Steve and I started planning opening a
brewery.
During this time, I was busy with another
business and Steve actually was called up
to Portland to house sit for his brother,
who was going on a long sabbatical and said,
"Hey.
Come house sit for me."
And he and his wife, Laura, went up to do
that.
While he was up there, he got a job at a brewery
called Pyramid.
Back before the Pyramid that you know today,
it was really a much earlier version of it.
And it was in Kalama, Washington, just north
of Portland, Oregon where that was.
It was still called Hart Brewing at that time.
And Steve got a job as a shift brewer.
And spring of 1995, I actually had gone down
to San Diego to see an old friend of mine
from college.
And I called up Steve and I said, "Hey.
How about San Diego?"
And he said, "Well, once my brother went to
school down in San Diego.
I really like it down there.
Yeah, I'd consider that."
So I moved down just a few weeks later and
started looking for a place to call the home
of what would be our brewery.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
So, you guys obviously agreed on it.
It was July 26th, 1996.
>>Greg Koch: It's happened a couple of times
in our 16-year history.
[laughter]
>>Randy Clemens: OK.
>>Greg Koch: Not too many.
>>Greg Koch: So, you find this spot.
It's in San Marcos, North County, San Diego.
It's an industrial park, kind of in the middle
of nowhere, kind of around nothing.
What was the initial reaction?
I mean, what did people think of the brewery
and what did people think of the beer?
>>Greg Koch: [sighs] So, craft brewing had
been, as you saw from that chart, had been
growing from around the 25 to nearly 55 percent
annual growth rate.
You can tell the year we opened, it was around
seven percent, if I remember correctly, but
then in our first year of business, 1997,
it went down to two percent.
So, it almost completely flattened out.
What did people think of our beer?
They thought our beer was bitter and somewhat
nearly undrinkable.
And the very first beer that we produced?
Stone Pale Ale.
Quite modest by today's standards.
We brew it exactly the same today as we did
then.
Here was a low-40s, in the IBU range, pale
ale.
And it was aggressive for a lot of people.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
You're gettin' it around town in this fancy
Ford Aerostar there.
>>Greg Koch: That's right.
>>Randy Clemens: Very nice.
[laughter]
We were self-distributed because, as I mentioned
earlier, none of the wholesalers were interested
in distributing our beer.
So, we started up our own distribution company,
which we jokingly called "Aerostar Distributing,"
with the panel van.
And that's when it was brand new.
We hadn't delivered a single keg of beer yet
that day, or yet at that time.
And unfortunately, we don't have a picture,
I don't think, of what it looked like when
we finally sold it off.
>>Randy Clemens: Yeah.
>>Greg Koch: I can just tell you that it would
go around the corner.
I would see it pull out of the brewery a few
years into it and it would go around the corner,
laden with kegs, and the van would turn like
this.
It would be like this squishy, bouncy thing.
And I'd go, "Yikes.
I hope we're gonna be OK."
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
And these are just some of the early tap handles,
which you self-harvested.
Is that correct?
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
So, I used to go to the beach in Cardiff and
find exact shape size configuration of stones
to then drill to add the ferrule on the bottom
and have them etched with the name of the
particular beers.
So, these are super old school and probably
somewhat collectible these days.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
So, you had these beers.
You had Stone Pale Ale, which--
>>Greg Koch: Mm-hmm.
>>Randy Clemens: people were telling you was
way too bitter.
So--.
>>Greg Koch: Not everyone, thankfully.
So, I don't wanna give the impression that
nobody liked our beer.
>>Randy Clemens: Sure.
>>Greg Koch: But I can tell you that--I'm
gonna sound like the old guy here now, but
you know--we had to walk uphill both ways
barefoot in the snow with a heavy load on
our shoulders.
It's not like today where we have--.
I can tell you, a roomful of people would
not have shown up to hear me talk.
[laughter]
Even with free beer.
I'm serious.
[laughter]
It was an odd time in our nation's history.
>>Randy Clemens: So, did you scale back?
>>Greg Koch: What?
Hell no.
>>Randy Clemens: OK.
[laughter]
>>Greg Koch: Is that my cue?
>>Randy Clemens: It's, yeah.
>>Greg Koch: Oh, it's my cue.
>>Randy Clemens: Yes.
>>Greg Koch: I'm gonna read a little--.
Excuse me.
[clears throat] May I read just a little bit
from the Stone book?
"The Craft of the Stone Brewing Company: Liquid
Lore, Epic Recipes, and Unabashed Arrogance,"
by Greg Koch, Steve Wagner, and Randy Clemens.
[clears throat]
[reads from book]
"Sticking to our guns.
So I remember telling you I was talking about
our bar buyers were telling us our Stone Pale
Ale was too bitter.
Sure, we could've listened and scaled back
on the hops, but we didn't want to.
It wasn't in our nature.
We were brewing beers that we liked to drink
and if they didn't like it, well, we'd find
other people who did.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
Instead of easing up, we went bolder.
“In August of 1997, we released Stone IPA
to celebrate our first anniversary.
IPAs are almost de rigueur now for most breweries,
but at the time, drinking an IPA was a new
experience for a lot of people's pallets.
Bitter?
Yes.
But the fresh flavors and aromas that came
from the hops--who knew beer could taste like
this?
Hop heads were being born and Stone was certainly
one of the delivery rooms.
“To quench this new thirst, we brewed ever-escalating
IPAs for the subsequent four anniversary celebrations,
going bigger and bolder each time, culminating
now with the somewhat legendary Stone fifth
anniversary IPA.
This hunger for hops was a good thing because
we were gearing up to release yet another
brew.
It was, and still is, an aggressive beer.
You probably won't like it.
It's quite doubtful that you have the taste
or sophistication to be able to appreciate
an ale of this quality, no?"
[laughter]
And that was, of course, the Arrogant Bastard
Ale.
>>Randy Clemens: So, I was going to ask who
here has had Arrogant Bastard Ale, but most
of us are drinking the Oaked version of it.
But if you're not, there's still some over
there.
But there was--.
>>Greg Koch: Seconds.
[laughter]
>>Randy Clemens: So, Greg just gave you a
tease on the back text label, the back label
text--excuse me--but there's this whole angle
of "you're not worthy."
And I think a lot of people have taken that
as a challenge or thought of it as brilliant
marketing.
And what's with that?
[laughter]
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
OK.
So, it wasn't.
So, when I wrote those words and continued
on with, I suppose, the insults or the elbow
to the ribs of the possible drinker, it was
really written to warn people away.
Because Arrogant Bastard Ale, we waited a
year and four months to come out with it,
even though we had created the recipe.
And by "we" I mean Steve 99 percent and me
one percent, but I'm gonna take my ownership
here.
We had created that recipe before we had actually
opened the breweries.
So we squirreled it away knowing that we were
gonna release it at some point, but waiting
until what we thought was a better time.
So, when we were producing it, I thought maybe
we would sell 100 cases.
I really didn't know, but I was quite certain
that there were not very many people out there
that could handle the beer.
So I wrote the label for the beer from that
angle trying to warn people away.
So one, they didn't just buy it and dump it
down the drain, which would've been painful
because I knew I loved the beer.
And two, because I never wanted to just goad
or talk somebody into trying our beer when
they probably wouldn't like it.
So, I literally tried to warn them away.
Now granted, I did have some fun with the
warning and throw that elbow in the ribs,
or hockey stick.
>>Randy Clemens: But the hundred cases sold?
>>Greg Koch: They sold quickly.
>>Randy Clemens: So you made more?
>>Greg Koch: We made more and it sold out.
And we made more and it sold out.
And now fast-forward years later, it's--.
Arrogant Bastard Ale is now the number one
selling single serve craft beer in US chain
stores.
Yeah.
[applause]
>>Randy Clemens: So, you've got these big
beers.
You've got Stone Pale Ale, Stone IPA.
You've got Arrogant Bastard Ale.
You're still bleeding money in the tune of,
I think you told me, 30 thousand dollars a
month.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah, so now we're talking.
So, Arrogant Bastard Ale came out November
1997.
Stone IPA came out a few months before that
in--it was either July or August.
Forgive me, I don't remember.
It's been a little while.
Of 1997.
And this little Ford Aerostar van that we
showed you cost a lot more money to run--it
was mostly the driver and the gas--than we
ever could have imagined.
And with every single case that we dropped
off at a beer store, and every single case
that we dropped off at a restaurant or a bar,
cost us more money than we took in.
So, if we dropped off a case of beer, we actually
lost probably--I think I calculated it once,
but only once because it was too painful to
do again--we were losing about five bucks
a case.
It's because we had no critical mass at all.
While the major brand brewer guy was going
and dropping off 30, 40 cases in a drop, we
were dropping off one, two--if we were lucky
and it was really lucky--maybe three cases
in a drop.
So there was no economies of scale.
And yeah.
We were bleeding 20, 30 thousand dollars a
month late through the second half of 1997
and into early-1998.
[pause]
>>Randy Clemens: What turned that around eventually?
>>Greg Koch: Well.
So we started talking to the big brand wholesalers
and also the wine and spirits wholesalers,
which some of which also carried beer, that
covered San Diego County in late-1997, early-1998,
in the hopes that one of them might be willing
to take our beer and distribute it.
And we could stem this bleeding.
I actually didn't feel very comfortable with
the idea because I knew that nobody was gonna
steward our beer to treat it and deliver it
and really, frankly, sell it the same way
we did because we're passionate, zealot geeks
and those guys sell boxes for a living.
It's the nature of it.
But we had no other choice.
So, we actually made an arrangement with one.
It was, it also doesn't exist anymore in San
Diego.
And we said, "OK."
They said, "We'll start distributing your
beer in December of 1997."
As that got close, they said, "You know what?
Let's start at the beginning of the year."
1998.
January 1998.
As that got close, they said, "You know what?
Super Bowl is gonna be in San Diego in late-January
1998.
We're gonna be so busy focused on that, we'll
start with you in February."
And in February--excuse me--in January, they
said, "You know what?
Our guys have--."
You seeing a pattern here?
"Our guys are gonna be so exhausted from working
so hard.
We're not gonna get their focus in February
because of Super Bowl--" which I hear is big
for the fizzy, yellow guys--
[laughter]
"We'll start with you in March."
And then, in the middle of February, I got
a phone call and our contact at this big brand
wholesaler said, "You know what?
We changed our mind.
We're not gonna distribute your beer.
We're too busy with other stuff.
So, thanks and the answer is we're not gonna
do it."
And I hung up the phone and I'm sure I was
as pale as a ghost.
And I actually can feel the lump in my throat--I
don't know if you can hear it in my voice--channeling
back to that time 'cause I walked over to
my partner Steve's office and I said--.
And I told him because what they had told
me was "We're not gonna work with you."
And what I heard was, "We're gonna let your
company die."
[pause]
And, strong imagery.
I can still feel that.
And it was really scary.
It was really, really scary.
But I didn't know how powerful--I gotta pull
myself out of this.
[laughter]
I didn't know how powerful March was.
And March 1998 happened and the weather warmed
up a bit.
And the sun shone and the clouds parted.
And we actually had our first break-even month.
We might've made a hundred bucks or even 200
bucks that month.
[laughter]
Which was a pretty brilliant thing when you're
losing at the rate we were.
And it was many months of up and down for
several years after that point.
So, we weren’t always in the black, but
that was when we knew that there was that
light at the end of the tunnel.
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
Well, I think anyone who's [clears throat]
talked to you or seen you over the years,
you're known for being a stickler and sticking
to your guns.
I just wonder if there's been a guiding principle
or a mission statement.
I glossed over that frame.
Sorry.
But there's Greg and Steve signing some bottles--giant
bottles of Arrogant Bastard Ale.
So, but yeah.
Essentially, I mean, how did you do it and
was there this guiding statement?
>>Greg Koch: So, back when we started, we
realized that we had strong philosophies about
beer, strong attitudes about beer.
Craft brewing, as I told you, had been growing
very rapidly before.
And so, there are a lot of great breweries,
so many great breweries.
Many, many, really iffy breweries, but there
was enough to really spark our imagination
of what beer could be.
And we were really inspired by that.
So, we decided to really just go for the styles
that we liked versus some of the styles that
were popular at the time.
Raspberry Hefeweizens were huge then.
[laughter]
No thanks.
So, I wanted to brew beer that was amazing,
that you could literally say, "Hey, while
not everybody might like this or might not
agree with my taste, I think we can look at
this and go, 'this has it.
This is for many people, and for myself, an
amazing beer.'"
And so we just tried to do things that we
thought were as amazing as we could.
>>Randy Clemens: There's a quote that you
like.
I thought of one that I like, but H.L. Mencken
quote.
>>Greg Koch: So, this quote from H.L. Mencken,
"Nobody ever went broke underestimating the
taste of the American public," was actually
a very foundational, philosophical item for
us because I wanted to be the exact opposite
of this.
When we started Stone, I said "This person
who was willing to be underestimated, I do
not want to brew beer for that person.
I wanna make beer for someone who doesn't
wanna be underestimated, who wants to be given
some credit for good taste."
>>Randy Clemens: All right.
And this one holds true for me.
George Carlin.
"America's most profitable business is still
the manufacturer, packaging, distribution,
and marketing of bullshit."
[laughter]
>>Greg Koch: Not if I have anything to say
about it.
>>Randy Clemens: Thankfully, but yeah.
It unfortunately holds true for a lot of industries.
And for me, why I got into the craft brewing
industry is that largely, this does not hold
true.
So, that's just my two cents.
And then--.
>>Greg Koch: We were still a commodity-driven
world, but we are showing each other through
the amazing work that so many artisanal producers
out there do, that it doesn't need to be just
this commodity world.
No longer are we stuck in the level that we
had in the '70s where you would go to a grocery
store and there would be two kinds of cheese--the
processed yellow one and the processed not
quite as yellow, dark yellow, one that had
holes in it, right?
And one kind of tomato--the flavorless beefsteak.
And vacuum-packed, freeze-dried coffee.
Who thought of that?
And where are they so I can smack 'em?
And bread was the stuff that was in the polka
dot plastic bag.
No longer.
I intentionally mentioned categories of food
that, I think, that most people in this room
would find completely unacceptable.
Forgive me if I'm wrong and you prefer vacuum-packed,
freeze-dried coffee.
One, OK.
[laughter]
I think it was a joking one, but our world
has changed a lot.
And I had a wonderful espresso on the way
over.
Where was that?
Do you remember the name?
Just down this street, this little funky little
place.
>>Randy Clemens: Groundworks maybe?
>>Greg Koch: Groundworks.
>>Randy Clemens: Groundworks is awesome.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
It was great.
Thank you, Groundworks.
[laughter]
>>Randy Clemens: Well, good.
Things have been changing.
It picked up.
Eventually, you started finding--.
The new problem was keeping up and keeping
enough space.
And so, you were expanding.
And then, there was a big move.
You went from your small, little San Marcos
brewery down a couple miles to Escondido.
>>Greg Koch: Over the years, we--.
We started off with over 700 square feet in
San Marcos.
And over the years, we added an adjacent suite
and then one more.
So, we added three times totaling 26 and a
half thousand square feet.
But then we were stuck.
We were landlocked within the building we
were in.
And also, we could see our capacity as far
as our 30-barrel brew house being exceeded
with the growth curve.
So, we projected ahead, realized that we needed
to find a spot--a new spot--to call home.
And that's when we started building this.
And we moved there in late-December 2005.
>>Randy Clemens: And with every nice house,
you need a kitchen attached.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
And so, I've always thought of us as Stone
and really the craft brewing industry as being
very much in the culinary world.
For decades and decades, even I would say,
several generations before, beer really hadn't
had a meaningful place at the dinner table
other than something to literally wash down
your food with, rather than actually enjoy
with your food.
And I felt that I wanted to showcase great
craft beer with great food.
And that's where the restaurant was born.
>>Randy Clemens: So, I mean, if you wanna
talk a little bit, too, about its design and
just--.
Here's an overview shot of just the scope
of what the restaurant really is.
>>Greg Koch: Well, we've had this philosophy
at Stone of don't be different to be different.
Be different to be better.
So, realizing this is our version of what's
better, it may not be everybody's version
and I always think that's OK 'cause that's
what brings us spice of life to our world.
Our version of better was just creating our
own ideals and putting them here.
So, we have a spot that is out of the way,
difficult to find, no sign on it.
How many people have actually had a chance
to visit?
[pause]
Wow.
From up here in LA, that was pretty impressive
that--.
Thank you, brothers and sisters.
[laughter]
It's difficult to find.
Am I right?
And, of course, the first two years that we
were open, Google Maps would send you to the
wrong place.
[laughter]
But it works now.
And so, we had a complete ban on high-fructose
corn syrup, which means no major brand sodas.
And of course, what is 99 point nine percent
of the restaurants and pubs in our country
serve?
Major brand sodas.
So that was a bit different.
And we had a complete ban on commodity beer
because, you know, you've heard me talk enough.
That just wasn't part of our world and not
part of what we wanted to foster and didn't
qualify for amazing.
If you look at something so simple as soda
or beer, there are ones that you can look
at and you can say, "You know, this qualifies
for amazing and this one doesn't."
And although we might not agree a lot of the
time, I'll bet 90 percent of the time we would--down
the check list--yes, amazing, no, not amazing.
We would probably come up with very similar
lists--even the people that choose the non-amazing
list.
Most of the people that drink commodity food,
or excuse me, or commodity beer or eat commodity
food know that they are making pretty mediocre
choices.
So, difficult to find.
No high-fructose corn syrup.
No commodity beer.
No TVs.
Difficult to find.
I said that again.
Organically-focused, so our prices are more
expensive.
A very eclectic menu, so not for the typical
pub grub approach.
And yet, we've been incredibly successful
with this restaurant.
>>Randy Clemens: And you were talking about
the beers.
You're not just serving Stone beers.
>>Greg Koch: Right.
Because my thought process was what's a more
amazing beer list?
An amazing line-up of Stone beers or an amazing
line-up of Stone beers plus an amazing line-up
of guest beers.
Well, that's a pretty easy one to decide.
I'm a beer geek.
I love other great craft beers.
So, we have 32 beers on tap.
Usually around eight to ten are Stone and
the rest are guest taps.
So, we actually have more guest beers than
our own beers.
And on our 130 bottle list, there's only two
or three are Stone and the rest are guest.
>>Randy Clemens: So, with that, you tend to
make some good friends in the industry.
I mean, for me, I've really seen just an amazing
sense of camaraderie amongst brewers.
Not just within San Diego, but across the
country.
And it's interesting to see something you
don't really see in other communities and
other industries.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
So, the great thing about craft beer is also
holds true in a lot of the non-commodity,
the artisanal side of the equation for a lot
of businesses--food, drink--but also hell,
the skateboard industry and other things like
that, in that we don't have to behave like
commodity.
Commodity, bring it down, make it appealing
to as many people as humanly possible, package
it in the way that supposes attributes that
really aren't there--"I'm better, in the case
of beer, I'm better looking.
I'm more sophisticated."--all these kinds
of things that they attribute to their brand.
And if you're in the commodity world, it's
all about that, beating the other guy, right?
I mean, look at Coke and Pepsi.
So, in the artisanal world, we get to appreciate
love, laud, share, seek after each others
beers.
Artisanal cheesemakers, artisanal bakers will
get together and appreciate what each other
is doing and so on and so on.
So, and certainly coffee roasters.
If anybody's ever been exposed to Coffee Common,
it's a collective of baristas that get together
at special events and they're from some of
the leading coffee roasters from around the
nation.
And these guys, it's amazing to be there.
I mean, really amazing.
>>Randy Clemens: So do you actually get--.
You work with other brewers from other breweries?
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
I think that was a long way of saying "yes"
to that, leading up to that.
>>Randy Clemens: OK.
>>Greg Koch: Thank you for helping me cycle
back around.
>>Randy Clemens: It was the next slide here.
OK.
>>Greg Koch: OK.
>>Randy Clemens: We're there now.
>>Greg Koch: So, it's a picture of me with
Sam, my friend Sam Calagione of Dogfish Head
Craft Brewery, from Delaware.
And from Victory Brewing, Bill Covaleski from
Victory in Downingtown, Pennsylvania.
And we got to create a beer together called
Saison Du BUFF a couple years ago.
Anybody have a chance to try that?
Oh.
Just one.
Well, your next chance everybody, is coming
up because this will be the first collaboration
beer that we've ever repeated.
We're brewing it all together again on May--.
>>Randy Clemens: Second.
>>Greg Koch: Thank you, Randy.
May 2nd, this year at Stone.
And both Dogfish Head and Victory have already
re-brewed, but not yet re-released their versions
'cause we all three brewed it at each one
of our three breweries.
When we did it two years ago, we all were
there at each brewery.
This year, we're only all getting together
at Stone.
And we're having an event.
I call it the Saison Du BUFFet.
[laughter]
So, awkward laughter there.
>>Randy Clemens: So, any collaborations on--?
Yeah, I thought it was funny.
>>Greg Koch: And by the way, Buff, B-U-F-F,
it's an acronym.
Stands for Brewers United for Freedom of Flavor
and it's an organization that Sam and Bill
and I created together in 2003.
And we wrote a manifesto decrying the power
of the fizzy, yellow commodity beers and need
for the media to pay just a little bit of
attention to the craft brewers.
And this was really just before the media
started to pay any attention to us.
We had a press release, a press conference
together and one person showed up.
[laughter]
And he was Jamie Magee from Yankee Brew News.
We had it in Boston and he was the only guy
that showed up.
No mainstream media at all.
Now, if we get the three of us together, we
can get some press and then people actually
think it's really cool and like, "Wow.
Look at these guys," and "These are some of
my favorite brewers."
It just goes to show you how things have changed
over just nine years.
I'm excited about it.
>>Randy Clemens: And collaborations play a
larger part.
I mean, there was this one obviously, but
we do them fairly regularly and we do a few
with home-brewers
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
We just had our American Home-brewers Association
rally at Stone last weekend.
And we have gotten to create some rock stars
out of the home-brewing industry, or industry
side of the equation.
>>Randy Clemens: Yeah.
So, well, it's that boom that you experienced
before is happening again.
And--.
>>Greg Koch: Well, I didn't experience the
first one.
>>Randy Clemens: Well--.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah, definitely.
It's boom time--
>>Randy Clemens: So, I mean--
>>Greg Koch: for craft brewers today.
>>Randy Clemens: do you attribute some of
that to technology that's now available?
>>Greg Koch: Unquestionably.
Because now enthusiasts, geeks--how many people
in this room are not geeks?
Wouldn't describe yourself as a geek?
OK.
So, we're at a hundred percent.
[laughter]
I would notice I didn't raise my hand.
I'm definitely consider myself a geek.
So, now is our time, brothers and sisters.
It's our world.
And is it not?
We get to communicate with each other in ways
that were previously interfered by the BMOC
guy, beatin' us out back behind school, OK?
So, now we can communicate with each other
and band together and actually make movement
in our world in a number of positive ways.
And communicating about things that are worth
communicating about is one of those things.
In the world of craft beer, we have RateBeer
and Beer Advocate, which have done tremendous
amounts of heavy lifting to just help connect
the dots with craft beer.
And, of course, social media has had a tremendous--.
It's tremendous power in communicating amongst
enthusiasts about, well, everything from craft
beer to I suppose Justin Beiber, but whatever.
>>Randy Clemens: Your two passions.
>>Greg Koch: Whatever you want.
>>Randy Clemens: Excellent.
[laughter]
>>Greg Koch: Exposed.
What was that song again?
>>Randy Clemens: You tell me.
>>Greg Koch: I don't know.
I thought I would catch him, but I didn't.
[laughter]
>>Randy Clemens: So, where do you see, I mean,
lightening round, the future of Stone?
>>Greg Koch: OK.
Lightening rounding with some slides here.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
So, we have a organic farm now.
Our local organic farm failed a year and a
half ago.
And a year ago, we stepped in to revive it.
So, we're proud to grow a lot of our own veggies
for the restaurant.
And--
>>Randy Clemens: Some for beers.
>>Greg Koch: Pardon?
>>Greg Koch: Oh, yeah.
Of course.
The Saison Du BUFF, which actually is a lyrically
themed beer, it's a Saison brewed with parsley,
sage, rosemary, and--
>>Audience: Thyme.
>>Greg Koch: thyme.
That's right.
It was delicious.
You know, the only person that had it was,
where?
I saw one hand raised.
And how did you like it?
>>Male #3: It was good.
>>Greg Koch: Good.
>>Male #3: I always try a Saison whenever
I can.
>>Greg Koch: So, we'll have a chance again.
But we grew all of the botanicals this year
for the Saison Du BUFF at Stone Farm.
>>Randy Clemens: And pumpkins for a previous
beer collaboration that we did?
>>Greg Koch: Yes, indeed.
Down in San Diego, there's an old Naval training
center.
It's called now Liberty Station and we're
working to go in and build--opening late this
fall, I hope--23 thousand square foot under
roof restaurant and brewery with about an
acre of outdoor space.
And then, we've got the Stone Packaging Hall,
which will go directly adjacent to our existing
brewery to allow us to continue to expand.
We'll kick all the bottling and kegging out
of our current building into this new building.
Well.
We're building this fancy new building.
And our current facility will continue to
expand as far as brewing capacity.
>>Randy Clemens: And then the proverbial money
shot.
[pause]
>>Greg Koch: Oh.
This is the first time this has been shared
on camera.
So, you guys will actually be the first to
unveil this.
This is the diagram for the, or the elevations
for the new Stone Hotel.
It's across the street from our brewery--or
will be--approximately two years from now.
Hopefully, just under.
We'll be breaking ground this summer.
Forty-eight rooms and a couple of unique features.
For example, each room will have a balcony
about five feet deep and 12 or 14 feet wide.
And on a nice day, you push a button and the
garage door that separates you from the outside
will roll up.
And just completely bleeding indoors and outdoors.
We won't have a check-in desk.
So, what do you do when you want your room
key?
Well, go to the bar of course.
[laughter]
You traveled to come here, so that's why you
need a hotel room and we figure you must be
thirsty.
[laughter]
And we'll have event space there intermixed
with a barrel aging room.
We're really, really ramping up our barrel
age program from spare barrels and also going
to be producing a number of sours.
We're very excited about that.
Me, well, everybody.
But I first got the chance to visit Cantillon
in 1995, the year before we opened Stone.
So, I've been a fan of Belgian sour styles,
traditional sour styles for a long, long,
long time.
So, it's been a long time coming as far as
I'm concerned.
[pause]
And another two acres of outdoor space for
specialty beer festivals and specialty beer
events.
And if anybody's thinking about getting married
or something, we'll accommodate you.
[laughter]
>>Randy Clemens: And all good stuff.
And I mean, if you can wax poetical a little
about just where you see the beer industry
going and continuing to go.
>>Greg Koch: Well, that slide, we're showing
the dip and the rise of the number of breweries
in the United States.
We now have somewhere over 22 hundred craft
breweries or breweries--the majority or vast
majority, which are craft breweries here in
the United States--with another 700 currently
on file in planning.
[pause]
This is incredible.
When Stone opened, there were about 800 breweries
in the United States.
And then, there was the downturn period where
as many were closing as were opening for a
number of years.
And now, we're in the age of nano.
We're in the age of continued, small breweries
opening up and yeah.
Where will that go?
I don't know.
It's really, it's fascinating.
Three years ago, the--it is.
Three years ago, the average American lived
within ten miles of a brewery.
That was three years ago.
That was probably a solid 500 breweries ago.
So, you could probably do a little guess work
on the math and think it's now within seven
miles the average American lives within a
brewery.
What can the United States, what can the market
bear?
I think we can handle a tremendous amount
of growth.
And I think things look really good.
Right now, craft beer represents about five
percent of the market.
And I think we can hit easy 20 percent.
What do you guys think?
Yeah?
[clapping]
Together we are heavy.
[laughter]
And it's exciting times.
I do just have a word to all the young brewers
who are starting up.
Be true to yourself.
Be true to craft beer.
Be true to the customers.
Don't try and chase after customers by doing
what you think they might want.
Try and do what you think is the right job.
And then, if you're good at it, people will
gravitate towards your beer.
But we have to be careful with so many breweries
opening up that we don't allow some of our
ranks to do things that bring all of us down.
And I don't think that that has to happen,
but I have a little bit of a fear it might
because if there's a bump in the road with
so much capacity and so many players out there,
that some might resort to desperate measures.
Stay strong, brothers and sisters.
>>Randy Clemens: With that, our part of the
presentation is done.
We can certainly open up to a couple questions
for Greg and I guess if you have some for
me.
But mostly if you have them for Greg.
>>Male #4: Hi.
So you were saying that you wanna make beers
that you love and also that you really love
trying other craft beers.
So, how strong is the temptation when you're
having somebody else's beer to like have some,
"Oh, that's really good.
I should make this."
Like, how do you prevent yourself from trying
to make everybody else's beer if you're trying
to make beer that you love?
>>Greg Koch: So, that's a great question.
I could answer it from a music perspective
'cause I came from the music industry before
brewing.
So, I'll give you a music analogy.
If you're a musician and you hear a song that
you love from somebody else, you don't necessarily
want to try and copy that, but you can love
it and respect it just as much.
Sometimes, what you do is go, "Oh, but the
way they did this particular lick or this
character of the song or the rhythm or something,
I think I know how I might use that in this
other thing that I had in the back of my mind."
So, just like a jazz musician can have classical
and thrash metal influences, it may show their
own little way through into the jazz that
they play.
We can sometimes be influenced by things that
you don't really see the connection to it,
but it filters through us creatively.
And this is the same with any artisanal endeavor
I think.
So, no.
I think we're often inspired, but rarely want
to copy.
There are some out there that are copying.
Hey, I don't wanna say like, "Well,--."
This doesn't suggest any copying because we
weren't the first ever to brew a double IPA,
but just to give you a perspective, Stone
Ruination IPA, when it came out in June of
2002, three, two, three, two.
Two.
OK, where was I?
So, Stone Ruination IPA, which came out in
June 2002 was the first full-time brewed and
bottled double IPA on the planet.
Not the first ever one that was ever brewed.
It was in, like, the first five arguably.
And now, how many double IPAs, how many breweries
are making double IPAs?
Were they copying us?
No.
But did we get inspired by, "Wow.
A beer can be uber-hoppy.
It can be super aromatic.
It can be a lot stronger than I thought people
would want to ever drink."
Because the average ABD was so much lower
at that time.
And we get inspired.
We do new things and we go in that direction.
[pause]
So, that's your answer.
>>Male #5: Well, if your--
>>Greg Koch: No, let's get the mic.
>>Male #5: I'm from San Diego, so I have a
huge appreciation for you guys.
Also a home-brewer Do you guys have, are you
growing your own hops at your--?
>>Greg Koch: At the farm?
>>Male #5: The farm.
>>Greg Koch: That's a question of do we grow
our own hops at Stone Farms?
The answer is only on a very, very anecdotal
basis.
We don't really have a functional hop growing
region in San Diego.
It is in the Pacific Northwest, where they
have longer days during the summer.
And just better overall micro-climate for
that.
So, we can better grow our veggies and service
the restaurant that way than growing hops,
which--.
We're losing money growing veggies at Stone
Farms.
We would really lose money growing hops at
Stone Farms.
And I'm not sure we'd get the yield or the
quality or the character that we would want
out of it.
>>Male #5: My follow-up is, do you have a
favorite hop?
>>Greg Koch: Do I have a favorite hop?
Wow.
I don't actually--.
I usually get the old, "What's your favorite
beer?"
question, which is an impossible question
to answer.
So, just for if anybody was thinking of asking
it.
Favorite hop.
No.
But I do have--.
I can mention some new hop styles which, I
think, are capturing my imagination and I
think a lot of people's imagination.
Citra hops qualify.
Amarillo, which isn't quite brand new, but
it's recent.
Those are a couple hops that I really love.
How about you, Randy?
>>Randy Clemens: I'll say Nelson.
Nelson Sauvin.
>>Greg Koch: Nelson Sauvin.
Yeah.
And when you go historically back, the beers
that are being brewed today could not have
been brewed historically.
They didn't exist.
While IPAs as a category have been around
for over a hundred years, originating in the
UK, they couldn't have tasted like they do
today because the hop varieties that are in
existence today were literally non-existent.
Cascade hops didn't even come around until
the '60s.
And what's different about the hops today
versus the noble varieties, the traditional
European varieties, are the big citrusy, piney,
floral, sometimes tropical fruit aromas that
you can get out of these varieties today.
They just didn't exist.
So, yeah.
It's a fascinating, wonderful time of actual
new discovery.
I can say that we are actually--music analogy
again--writing new songs that couldn't have
been written.
Sometimes you say, "Every note has been played.
Every bit of music has already been created
before and we're just rehashing."
And you can say that about brewing from one
angle, but from another angle you can say
no.
That's not true.
We're actually creating new styles that couldn't
have possibly existed.
You couldn't get the flavor and aromatic profiles
of many of the beers that are being brewed
by craft brewers today, historically.
[pause]
>>Male #6: How do you explain such a renaissance
of craft beer scene in San Diego and a full
out wipe-out happen in Los Angeles?
>>Greg Koch: I can actually answer that.
I lived in Los Angeles for 12 years, from
'84 to, I guess it was 11 years now that I'm
doing that.
'95.
And craft beer got an early start in Los Angeles,
but it was a rocky start.
Wolfgang Puck started his Eureka Brewing Company,
which was a very notable failure.
And there was Rhino Chasers, which was a contract
brewed brand that was based out of the Los
Angeles region.
Also ended up being a notable failure.
Gorky's, which was around, ended up failing.
Anybody ever go to Gorky's back in the day?
One.
Awesome.
I was there, too.
>>Male #6: Not far from Al's.
>>Greg Koch: Not far from Al's Bar.
That's right.
[laughter]
You guys think I'm lousy.
Downtown LA.
And there were some beach breweries within
the beach area of Los Angeles.
They were really brewing mediocre beer and
some of them were just faking it with fake
takes and actually having the beer contract
brewed for them.
There was so much going on in the beer industry--the
craft brewing industry--in LA that wasn't
real or failed notably that it put a pall
on LA for a number of years.
So, when Steve and I both were looking at
starting a brewery, we thought to ourselves,
"We don't wanna this in LA.
This is not a good place for craft beer."
And that's why we moved down to San Diego
because we thought there was more of an opportunity.
[pause]
But then, now why San Diego?
So, in San Diego, we have had the luck of
having a number of really amazing quality
inspired, creative brewers.
And I think if we've done anything at Stone,
is we helped set the example that you could
go where the market wasn't.
And the market didn't think it wanted to go
or didn't know it wanted to go.
And you could go that direction and you could
be successful with it.
So, as other brewers saw us taking all these
left turns and going big and going odd and
such, other breweries said, "Wait.
Well, you know?
We'll break out of the amber ale, golden ale,
hefeweizen, dry stout, and premium golden
ale categories and start branching out into
more unique styles."
>>Randy Clemens: And I'll add in real quick.
Just, I mean, there is great stuff happening
now in LA.
I mean, you got, certainly there's great beer
bars, but Craftsman Brewing Company up in
Pasadena has been there since 1995.
>>Greg Koch: Yeah.
>>Randy Clemens: You've got Eagle Rock Brewery
that's open in Eagle Rock a few years ago,
a little over two years ago.
El Segundo, really close to here.
Rob's doing some great stuff there.
His Wheat IPA is fantastic.
His Hyperion's Stout's great.
And there's other people.
If you're up Agoura Hills way, there's Ladyface
Ale Companie.
There's some really cool stuff happening now.
And I think there might be something again
its infancy.
>>Greg Koch: I think LA is coming into its
renaissance time for craft beer definitely.
This is good time.
I think all the way in the back.
Last, a last--.
>>Male #7: Is there a East Coast/West Coast
rivalry?
I'm from New England and I know there's a
lot of good craft beers up there.
I feel like some of the ones back East taste
a little different.
Is there a different styles or different--?
You talked about--.
>>Greg Koch: Is there East Coast/West Coast
rivalry in craft brewing?
Well, I worked with my friend, Sam, from Delaware
at Dogfish.
I did take him into the hop cooler and feel
compelled to actually say, "By the way, these,
we call them hops."
[laughter]
To which he said, "Oh, good one Greg."
Not so much rivalry.
I think it's only poetry slam rivalry level,
which we have a lot of respect for each other.
And we love throwing elbows and making fun,
but then give me another one of your delicious
beers that you brew 'cause I really like what
you do.
Yeah.
>>Male #8: So, I had a baby about a year ago.
My wife had the baby.
[laughter]
>>Greg Koch: I'm glad you're clear on that.
>>Male #8: And I had just thought stopped
home-brewing and I'd been drinking mostly
Stone IPAs since then because damn they're
good.
They're all just as good as my home-brew And
I--.
Because what I discovered was the worst home-brew,
as long as it didn't skunk out, was better
than almost any beer you could reliably find
except for Stone.
So, what advice might you have for home-brewers
or things that home-brewers who want to get
closer to what you guys are doing in terms
of density and richness and alcoholic content
and that sort of thing?
What are home-brewers not doing that they
could be doing to get a better beer?
>>Greg Koch: Nice segue for buying our book,
which has home-brew recipes in it.
[laughter]
Or my other book called "The Brewer's Apprentice."
But no.
Other than showing my book, the answer to
that is as a home-brewer, the best piece of
advice I can ever give: join a home-brew club.
Start home-brewing with somebody else just
like I did with Steve, who was much more advanced
at the time we started home-brewing when we
worked together than I was.
So, I had the benefit from learning from somebody
else.
And he had learned from a friend of his.
So, instead of just opening up a book, no
matter how brilliantly written and well-designed
it might be,--
[laughter]
get together with friends because brewing,
home-brewing with friends, of course, is a
great way to do it.
And you amplify your learning curve by doing
what people who have been doing it.
So, I recommend get together with home-brewers
And the American Home-brewers Association--fantastic
resource for that.
[pause]
>>Female Presenter: Great.
Well, it's time for Happy Hour.
So, let's give a big hand to Greg and Randy.
>>Greg Koch: Thank you very much.
[applause]